jean pierre raffarin est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir michel
confirmé à tous et merci d'être avec
nous donc pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec l' agence france-presse
ce soir n'a des speeds ac avec bien sûr
également perrine tarneaud quel premier
ministre n'a jamais eu recours à
l'article 49 voix pour faire adopter un
texte sans vote alors est-ce que vous
jeter la pierre à manuel valls au nom du
syndicat des anciens premiers ministres
je ne jette pas la pierre à l'actuel
premier ministre
la situation aujourd'hui révèle une
évidence il n'ya plus de majorité
gouvernementale
c'est quand il n'ya plus de majorité
gouvernementale que les institutions ont
donné au premier ministre le recours aux
49 3 pour imposer son autorité face à
une majorité dispersement vous l'avez
utilisé deux fois je me sens absolument
c'est les règles constitutionnelles on
est attaché aux règles de la
constitution va pas reprocher lusage de
la constitution un problème il parce que
maintenant ses propres fossoyeurs de sa
majorité
alors d'abord ce qui est clair c'est le
constat de divisions
parce qu'on parle des frondeurs à
l'intérieur du ps mais il ya quand même
les écologistes il ya le front de gauche
parti communiste et front de gauche il y
a maintenant les frondeurs donc on voit
bien qu'il ya une grande dispersion et
donc l'exécutif actuellement ne réussit
pas à rassembler donc moi je ne reproche
pas l' usage du 49-3 outils
constitutionnels
je constate que la majorité actuelle
n'est plus une majorité rassemblée mais
c'est une majorité dispersé quelle
conclusion pour l'action du gouvernement
je pense que le gouvernement a raison
d'avancer je pense que c'est un peu
dommage de sortir des outils
institutionnels aussi lourd que le 49-3
pour des lois aussi légère vous aviez
parlé oui d'un bulldozer pour les
châteaux de sable je pense que
globalement c'est beaucoup de bruit pour
pas grand chose
la loi macron à un certain nombre
d'éléments qui sont des éléments plutôt
positif que vous auriez voter que nous
pourrions voter nous avons nous au sénat
enrichit le texte si on tient compte de
notre enrichissement nous le voterons si
on n'en tient pas compte on votera
contre
mais au total ce qui a été fait par le
gouvernement
on est assez superficielle le sénat a
bien travaillé nous on propose de
doublement des seuls vous étiez officiel
mais mais manuel valls y plaide sa cause
aujourd'hui encore en défendant le 49 3
et dit qu'il veut aller vite au nom de
l'efficacité et l'économie qu il dit
faux nom il a raison il a il avait
raison il a raison pour un premier
ministre qui doit avancer et donc il
cherche à avancer factions que je avec
des mesures efficaces pour l'économie je
pense que ces mesures ne sont pas
efficaces
aucune je pense que si vous voulez c'est
le problème du pays c'est pas les
notaires le problème du pays c'est pas
d'aller en autocar de paris à marseille
le problème du pays c'est les pme c'est
le développement de économique c'est
notre agriculture ces logements c'est un
bâtiment
c'est ce qui fait l'emploi va corbella
grand temps que deux grands sujets dans
le pays lui l'emploi et la sécurité et
donc c'est ce sur ces sujets qu'il faut
travailler sur l'emploi il ya des
mesures en faveur des entreprises
le plafonnement des indemnités aux
prud'hommes par exemple les parcs
salariale les possibilités de crédit
entre entreprises tout ça ce sont des
mesures que vous auriez pu voter et
prendre mais elles sont mineures quand
vous marque de somme le champion du
monde des impôts champion du monde des
charges que nous avons aujourd'hui des
pme beaucoup moins compétitives que les
pme britanniques ou les pme allemandes
moi ce que je demande c'est une
harmonisation progressive de nos
paramètres avec la grande bretagne et où
avec l'allemagne donc nous avons des
réformes de fond à faire sur notre code
du travail il y a des choses lourdes à
faire et on nous propose des choses qui
sont périphériques alors sorti une arme
un bazooka du 49-3 pour des mesures
aussi légère c'est ça qui est à
reprocher c'est pas les accords
institutionnels avec la conclusion que
vous en tirez donc que le gouvernement
n'a plus de majorité
il veut plus rien se passer j'espère
qu'il va se passer des choses parce que
la situation du pays est très grave et
j'espère que le premier ministre va
prendre conscience de la gravité de la
situation qu'est ce que vous lui de
congé
moi je considère que les mesures sur les
pme c'est une bonne introduction la
direction est bonne il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin
il faut que baisser l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour le capital réinvestis il
faut baisser les charges
il faut faire en sorte que
aujourd'hui on supprime le savez déjà la
majorité qui s'effrite jean pierre
raffarin lui il lui reproche de faire la
politique du medef il va pas aller plus
loin
ça c'est un vrai sujet est ce qu'il ya
une politique de gauche une politique de
droite en matière économique pour ces
questions de développement des
entreprises
moi je réponds comme tony blair il n'y a
pas la politique de gauche il n'y a pas
la politique de droite il ya la
politique qui marche et donc la
politique qui marche c'est celle qui
donne de l'énergie aux entreprises et
c'est cette politique qu'il faut mener
le premier ministre semble dans son for
intérieur avoir un peu entendu cette
musique et donc quand je l'entends
présenté le programme pme tpe
je dis cela il a peut-être compris il va
dans la bonne direction mais s'arrête à
la première marche
il ya tout un escalier à monter d'accord
mais enfin il peut alors en bas des
escaliers il peut vous séduire jeu comme
emmanuel macron peut vous séduire je
pense que ce qui va dans le sens d entre
eux munis de l'emploi va dans le bonne
direction et donc notre travail c'est
pas de dire au premier ministre qu'il se
trompe tout le temps notre travail c'est
de dire quand il va dans la bonne
direction il va dans la bonne direction
sur le renseignement
j'ai voté le terrain il va dans la bonne
direction sur la loi de programmation
militaire
nous allons qu'amendé mais nous allons
aller dans cette direction avec en
revanche sur l'économie aujourd'hui il
nous montre des intentions qui ne nous a
pas encore démontré sa capacité d'action
au service de l'emploi on parle de
l'emploi mais l'emploi n'est pas au
coeur de la politique économique du
gouvernement à se gérer en fait le
constat il est quand même entraver mais
vous vous encouragements jean pierre
raffarin au premier ministre j'ai
presque envie de parler de compliments
il s'adresse aussi au chef de l'état
écoutez je parle à l'exécutif le chef de
l'état aujourd'hui est dans une
situation qui me paraît un peu
préoccupantes pour le pays
si c'est vrai qu'il a lancé sa campagne
si c'est vrai qu'il est obsédé par
l'élection
si c'est vrai que deux manifestations
manifestation il ne s'occupe de son
image il se trompe gravement
car pour les français le résultat sera
jugé en fonction des paramètres de
l'emploi et paramètres de sécurité le
taux et aurait les hautes dunes et le
rejet de toute campagne électorale
anticipée est une grave erreur et s'il
regarde bien
l'état de l'opinion s'il regarde ce
qu'ont été les élections municipales ce
qu'ont été les élections départementales
ce que sont toutes les partiels les unes
après les autres et il faut pas penser
que les régionales seront suffisamment
significative car s'il compte sur le
front national pour avoir en apparence
quelques satisfactions il se trompe
lourdement
car à la présidentielle c'est la
sanction qui se plaint du poids de
rester cloîtrés j je mérite loi drainage
et emploi et sécurité et que sur ces
sujets là il ne trace pas un programme
simplement pour 2017 mais qui pense à
l'avenir de la faune moi je pense qu'il
nous faut un programme d'harmonisation
qui est un programme à l'horizon 2025
par exemple avec l'allemagne alors vous
aurez l'occasion tout à l'heure de
préciser justement vos propositions en
répondant aux questions de perrine
tarneaud à la ferme isolée vous demander
mes bonnes réponses aux femmes et que
vous prenez les mauvais formulé de bon
je vais tout à fait acceptable cette
émission mais faire des efforts est ce
que vous croyez encore à la capacité de
françois hollande de se représenter
bien sûr le président de la république
la fonction présidentielle permet à tous
ceux qui l'occupent de pouvoir se
représenter donc soyons clairs la
fonction présidentielle dans d'autres
pays c'est quelque chose de très
important
même quand j'aurai côté du costume
on est très faible ça pèse quand même
20% le costume à lui sa vie serait ce
quasiment 20%
donc la qualification sous l'eau qui se
trouve un document les barreaux mais
d'opinion au nord de 25%
donc ça veut dire qu'un président
sortant peut toujours avoir des
circonstances qui lui permettent d'être
il a ses chances donc on ne peut pas
exclure un scénario de continuité dans
la vème république française ce n'est
pas un jugement sur monsieur hollande
c'est un regard institutionnel sur le
poids de la fonction malgré les mots
très durs employés par nicolas sarkozy à
son encontre qui avait parlé de cette
terrible médiocrité ça vous a choqué
cette expression qu'on se marre chef de
l'état je pense que le chef de l'état à
passe à côté d'un certain nombre de
grands sujets aujourd'hui donc il y un
jugement est très sévère dans le pays si
on veut être objectif on compte
après un antisarkozysme partiel mais il
ya un anti hollande qui se développe
très fortement et c'est ce qui rend la
situation du pays d'ailleurs moins
dangereuse parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont plus antique pour quelque chose et
ça fait naturellement le lit du front
national
donc faut être vigilant françois
hollande est très actif également sur
les dossiers internationaux enfin très
visible on le voit se déplacer il était
en algérie pour un voyage express ce
lundi pour un entretien avec le
président bouteflika vous suivait le
dossier algérien de très près jean
pierre raffarin le président bouteflika
qui anime et selon françois hollande
d'une grande vivacité intellectuelle
quand il l'a dit vous avez souri
écoutez j'ai rencontré pendant plus de
deux heures le président bouteflika il
ya un mois et demi et je peux vous dire
que sa vélocité intellectuelle est
intacte vraiment il est handicapé
physiquement pour se mouvoir mais les
questions qu'il m'a posé sur la
politique française sur ycompris ce qui
se passerait aux régionales sur les
questions financières internationales le
président bouteflika m'est apparu comme
ayant des capacités intellectuelles
qu'on lui tende et vous parlez vous de
vivacité françois hollande dalle la
crypte et franchement les images que
l'on voit que l'on a vue ne semble pas
correspondre correspond à la définition
du larousse forcément écouté très
franchement soyons très très prudent sur
ce sujet mais il est dit beaucoup de
choses avant que je le vois c'est une
personnalité qui a aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de difficultés à se
mouvoir ce qui donc donne le sentiment
extérieure d'un affaiblissement
mais quand il parle il a une vivacité
je vous assure que il est allé dans les
détails d'un certain nombre de projets
que je connais bien pour les parents les
plaisirs d'un mensonge qui est infligé
au peuple algérien qui n'est pas due
peut écouter les relations avec
l'algérie sont extraordinairement
complexes ce qui est très important
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on appelle la
france la france où es tu là et à chaque
fois qu'il peut y avoir une occasion de
faire des progrès dans la relation
franco algérienne
nous sommes liés par un destin nous
sommes une communauté de destin il y à
du tragique dans notre histoire mais il
ya aussi des personnes
active et ses perspectives la faune que
nous avons un devoir d' attention
vis-à-vis des uns et des autres nous
avons des intérêts communs et nous avons
appelé mais je n'ai par exemple le
principal opposant au président
bouteflika
ali benflis qui s'était présenté
l'ancien premier ministre qui s'était
présenté contre lui il lui il évoque une
vacance du pouvoir aujourd'hui s'ils se
trompent
je pense que le rôle de la france
aujourd'hui c'est de travailler avec les
autorités algériennes
ces autorités algériennes ont tous
ouvert un certain nombre de pistes de
coopération dans les périodes récentes
qui sont très significatives et si on
veut améliorer durablement la relation
entre la france et l'algérie
il faut répondre à ses impulsions
algérienne aujourd'hui exprimer donc le
président de la république sur ce sujet
est vraiment dans la mission qui est la
sienne de penser à l'avenir de la france
et à l'avenir de la relation entre la
france et l'algérie cet avenir là il est
un avenir en partie commun il faut
l'intégrer avec nadja que première femme
qui va nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
donc jean pierre raffarin nadège de
respect nous allons maintenant aborder
la situation chez les républicains y at
il eu un élan après le congrès fondateur
et qui en profitent plus tient dans le
cadre des primaires
d'abord jérôme rabier évoque un
changement qui vous touchent directement
avec la fin des courants notamment donc
les humanistes que laisser vivre jusque
là l'ump
pour certains la fin de l'ump la
naissance du parti les républicains
n'est qu'un changement de façade mais
derrière la vitrine les statuts eux ont
bien évolué fini les courants équivalent
d'émotion socialiste les républicains
invoquent désormais sous un seul et même
étendard on l'a dit dans les statuts on
est tous républicains
on est tous ensemble maintenant ça
n'empêchera pas le moment venu chacun de
faire ses choix sur des projets ou des
propositions les courants c'était le
risque de de transformer les cours en
écurie présidentielle c'est à dire que
le responsable de chaque courant peut te
pouvait se trouver le des velléités
d'être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et c
- inverse de ce que nous voulons mais
une même étiquette n'efface pas les
différences d'autant que les écuries des
présidentiables derrière lesquelles se
rangent leurs soutiens sont en passe de
les remplacer alors pour maintenir son
influence la droite forte qui était le
courant arrivé en tête en 2012
combien toujours s'appuyer sur sa
sensibilité je donne donc priorité aux
sensibilités la mienne c'est la droite
forte et même si l'émotion humeur les
sensibilités demeure plutôt qu aux
écuries qui honnêtement n'intéresse pas
grand monde ou qui les intéresseront
mais seulement en temps voulu des
courants on est donc passé aux
sensibilités sans vraiment savoir
quelles tendances pèse le plus au sein
du parti
de quoi faire regretter l'ump à certains
le problème c'est qu'un débat d'idées
possible à l'ump on va avoir
je crains des querelles de personnes ou
république halle avec les courants ça
permettait que chacun puisse s'exprimer
ça permettait éventuellement à un moment
que les militants puissent s'exprimer et
qui est une position de prise il n'y a
pas de courant c'est à dire que j'ai
l'impression qu'on va mettre un peu
comme d'habitude chacun va faire des
déclarations dans tous les sens et à la
sortie on sera même pas quelle est la
position du mouvement
un mouvement voulu par nicolas sarkozy
pour recoller les morceaux d'une ump
éclater la course à la primaire qui
démarre déjà un an et demi avant le vote
sera un crash test efficace pour voir si
l'unité de façade ou durable voilà
bonsoir monsieur raffarin quelle voix de
stentor s'amasser pour m'impressionner
on voit du mal je sais alors les
courants ont disparu on appelait
engagement les sensibilités vous dites
dois-je vous aligner un courant qu'ils
avaient les humanistes arias plus
d'humaniste à l'ump a au pardon aux
républicains les plus humanistes ya
toujours des humanistes et sont
relativement nombreux mais je regrette
cette décision parce que je crois que le
débat d'idées a besoin de confrontations
de penser et que un parti ça ne
s'organise pas qu'en fonction des
individualités mais ça s'inscrit aussi
en fonction de paul de conviction on
peut pas dire que l'idée libérale n'est
pas là quelque chose d'assez bien défini
la pensée humanisme et égaux si quelque
chose de bien défini je crois qu'il y a
dans notre tradition des nécessités à ce
qu' il ya un travail de penser quand la
droite forte plus bonapartiste fait
référence à des courants historiques
je respecte cette droite forte nous
devons avoir des discussions des
alliances des compromis nous devons être
rassemblées parce que le front national
est menaçant nous avons donc des
différences mais si les différences ne
sont pas exprimés si les différences
sont mêlés et que hors en place
humaniste libéral bonapartiste
orléaniste par juppé fillon sarkozy et
tout ça va vous parler votre guide n'y
aura pas de confrontation c'est bien
qu'il y en aura des confrontations
la primaire va arriver dans combien
maintenant 18 mois je pense qu'il faut
avoir des confrontations d'idées je
pense que ça vaut la peine de réfléchir
ensemble pour moi la dignité de la
politique déjà c'est la cohérence entre
une pensée et une action en quoi je suis
moi même de mon point de vue cohérent
dans une action politique c'est que j'ai
un certain nombre de valeurs et que ce
que je fais et bien je le fais en
fonction de ses valeurs c'est la
cohérence entre une pensée et une action
et les avis et alors si on a pas de
débat de penser ça veut dire que
l'action que le pragmatisme que au fond
on aura un certain nombre de débats qui
ne seront que des débats assez technique
sans orientation de penser la vie
politique c'est aussi de la pensée moins
directe l'ump alors les vins les
républicains je pense que les
républicains c'est une approche positive
ça a été un rassemblement je crois que
c'était très significative parce que ça
vous a peut être échappé mais avec le
départ d'un certain nombre de centristes
qui ont constitué lui dit legrand en
juin 2011
c'était de savoir si c'est tu dis allez
devenir l'udf pour que cette udi
redevienne ce qu est l udf serait qui ce
qui aurait signifié que l'ump redevienne
le maire
et il fallait pour cela que des
centristes des humanistes des libéraux
de l'ump quittent le mouvement pourrait
s'amuser par lui dire ça c'est un
proposition
ça ne s'est pas produit c'est à dire que
le scénario bipolaire udf et à pep est
abandonnée et que nous sommes dans un
scénario de rassemblement
les républicains mais dans ce
rassemblement je souhaite que les
sensibilités existe car moi je ne me
définit pas en fonction d'un candidat
aujourd'hui je me définis en termes de
penser justement des idées vous allez
pouvoir en exposer puisque nicolas
sarkozy qui a été ma devant les députés
ce matin et aussi devant les sénateurs
je peux je suppose que vous étiez là
aussi a redit qu'il fallait réfléchir
sur tous les sujets y avait pas de sujet
tabou y compris l'immigration le droit
du sol
alors justement ce droit du sol dont on
parle tant est ce que c'était utile
d'ouvrir le débat
maintenant je crois que c'est utile
d'ouvrir le débat pourquoi je pour le
remettre en cause parce que parce que je
pense que la situation dans notre pays
devient une situation de tension très
préoccupante
je vous assure qu' il ya aujourd'hui un
sentiment dans le pays
comme quoi l'étranger pourrait être
menaçants et ça c'est très grave il faut
lutter contre ce sentiment là et donc il
faut pas laisser s'installer dans le
pays avec ses vagues migratoires
un sentiment qui serait contraire des
valeurs de la france pour cela il faut
en parler cacher les problèmes ça ne
signifie pas qu'on est capable de les
résoudre
mais ça veut dire en clair qu'il faut
bien ça va et droit du sang il faut il
faut discuter
moi je pense que je suis favorable au
droit du sol mais il ya peut-être un
certain nombre de cas sur lesquels il
pourrait être être un débat ouvert sur
le sujet je pense qu'il faut montrer aux
français que tout ce que nous avons dit
sur l'immigration il y a 20 ans doit
être aujourd'hui revisitée
car le niveau de l'immigration n'est
plus du tout le même et donc nous avons
à aujourd'hui à organiser une société
sereine et apaisée et c'est certainement
pas en laissant le sentiment que les
français aujourd'hui non pas deux
d'attitude ouverte sur l'asile par
exemple qu'on va résoudre la question de
l'abaissement de la france je vous cite
un exemple nous avons par exemple dans
notre monde rural un déficit
démographique très important on est très
souvent dans la situation offert des
écoles on pourrait très bien sauvé assez
grand nombre d'écoles en en faisant en
sorte une deux ou trois familles
puissent venir dans un certain nombre
assez les quotas s'assurer qu'ottawa
d'état n'ont pas forcément pas forcément
savent ça veut dire qu'on pourrait
accueillir et donc et ça on ferait en
sorte que le l'étranger au lieu de venir
déranger et vient sauver un territoire
il participe à la dynamique et 6,7 à
doses qui sont des doses humainement
acceptables par les uns et par les
autres l'intégration était en
globalement réussie et donc je crois
qu'il faut aménager sur moi j'ai une
opinion je pense qu'il faut reconstruire
une pensée de l'immigration et pour cela
il faut évidemment repenser schengen
il faut harmoniser l'europe il faut
faire un certain nombre de choses il
faut pas se dire on va défendre le droit
du sol le droit du sang ouais non au
thon peut discuter de tout nicolas
sarkozy a raison sur ce plan on peut
discuter de tout moi j'ai une vision
très positif et humaniste du sujet mais
je ne veux surtout pas nier les
problèmes qui sont posés dans un certain
nombre de quartiers où la ronde et et
vous avez la concentration et du
communautarisme vous êtes pour des
centres d'accueil pour les migrants qui
viennent qu'en france sur éclairé comme
le droit d'asile à ma question est posée
c'est très difficile j'en ai un dans mon
département dans le département de la
vienne 80 personnes qui vont s'installer
à loudun je pense que c'était très mal
présentés je pense qu'à terme la
population et croquis des petites
équipes intégrées mais bien présente et
bien présente et nous avons un centre
afpa qui était un centre afin qu'ils
étaient condamnés convainc réhabilité à
cette occasion il ya du positif dans le
sujet mais tout ça devrait être expliqué
et non pas donner le sentiment que c'est
quelque chose qui est fait contre le
territoire
c'est quelque chose qui peut être utile
aux terroristes que mais pour cela il
faut consulter
il faut discuter il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui d'accompagnement et donc il
n'y a pas de débat serein sur
l'immigration on cache le système on
laisse le front national avoir un
discours
n'ayez pas encore après les quatre
parfois il impose son discours c'est un
sujet
très important pour moi il nous faut une
vision humaniste mais responsable de
l'immigration
c'est à dire avec des limites avec une
politique de schengen révisé et donc
avec une responsabilité française h et
c'est tout ce que vous allez dire
pendant la convention qui aura lieu sur
l'immigration puisque monsieur sarkozy a
annoncé une prochaine convention sur
l'immigration
ce sont ces sujets là que voulait
absolument absolue a passé une
convention
alors je rappelle juste que claude
guéant qui était l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur de monsieur sarkozy il a dit
aujourd'hui que c'était difficile de
revenir sur le droit du sol un qui est
profondément inscrit dans l'histoire de
france parlant vous n'êtes pas tout à
fait d'accord avec lui sur ce toit mais
non c'est vrai que le droit du sol et
profondément inscrit dans notre histoire
il lui dit c'est difficile de revenir là
dessus
oui mais je pense qu'il ya certains cas
on peut discuter d'un certain nombre de
choses moi ce que je ne veux pas donner
le sentiment aux français c'est que par
parisianisme par esprit bobo tous à ces
sujets là c'est pour les français nous
la classe dirigeante l'immigration
connais pas moi je veux pas être
maintenant parce que les français ils
sont face au problème de l'immigration
et donc il n'y a pas de sujet qu'on ne
peut pas aborder y compris le droit du
sol que l'on est après dans le débat une
vision qui est plus restrictive ou plus
humaniste ça c'est un autre sujet mais
moi je considère que les français sur ce
sujet sont exaspérés et qui vaut mieux
les écouter plutôt que de les étouffer
alors parmi les sujets qui fâchent
justement il ya l'islam vous avez fait
une journée de travail sur l'islam le 4
juin
ça a été très critiquée et surtout par
la gauche et pas seulement également
chez vous un certaines personnes ont
critiqué alors on n'a pas eu d'écho sur
ces travaux qu est ce que vous êtes dit
pendant cette journée parce que les
sujets sont des sujets de réflexion
difficile et qu'on ne peut pas tout
résumer en des slogans et en quelques
minutes de télévision lève le sujet ions
sur le sujet de l'islam
c'est un c'est un sujet extrêmement
difficile est ce que il existe un islam
modéré par exemple c'est cette question
fondamentale ya un certain nombre de
gens y compris mme on dirait qu'il me
dit non il n'ya pas d'islam modéré
moi je pense qu'il ya un islam modéré
mais comment peut-on le définir et
comment peut-on faire en sorte qu'il y
ait de la place dans notre république
pour un islam modéré ces sujets là et
peuvent être développées
et discuter donc nous sommes en train de
discuter mais franchement que la gauche
nous reproche de discuter du stade
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
parce qu'il n'ya pas un problème
aujourd'hui quand même dans notre pays
sur ces sujets ça veut dire qu'on le nie
le problème
interrogé un peu les français sur le
sujet vous verrez que pour lui un
problème donc où et comment définir ou
est-ce que nous allons je pense que il
ya une une forme de crainte et une peur
que si vous n'acceptez validé qui a dit
cela modéré l'islam va dériver vers de
l'islamisme et à ce moment là vous créer
de la peur parce que vous vous avez
franchi un certain nombre de limites de
sécurité qui font peur aux gens
donc la question fondamentale c'est
comment on peut faire en sorte que deux
bonne foi il y à un islam qui se
développe dans notre pays qu'ils soient
compatibles avec les règles de la
république ait compris la laïcité
oui à l'exercice religieux dans notre
pays non à ce que l'exercice religieux
devienne un projet politique donc il
nous avons un certain nombre de choses à
clarifier de cette nature mais
franchement penser qu'il n'y a pas de
débat sur l'islam dans notre pays c'est
pas écouter les français et la crainte
de ne voir à un moment les islamistes
pesé lourd dans la société française
alors je vois passer à un tout autre
sujet les primaires tout à l'heure vous
disiez qu'il fallait qu'on une
confrontation constructive dans votre
partie ce sera peut-être le cas pour ces
primaires ou bien est-ce que ça peut
dégénérer en écurie en bataille
personnelle dgo comment ça se passe ici
primaire temps de la préparation de ces
primaires d'abord moi je souhaiterais
que ça ne se passe pas trop vite parce
que je pense que la primaire elle doit
démarrer à peu près dans un envoi la
loire j'appartiens l'avoir le tas de
mots c'est pour ça que je crois qu'il
vaut mieux aujourd'hui s'attacher un
certain nombre de sujets collectifs où
on parle avec juppé avec fillon avec
sarkozy avec les uns avec les autres
un certain nombre de sujets y compris
l'immigration y compris l'islam des
sujets sur la croissance sont les
relations franco allemandes
on a un certain d'une bonne dizaine de
sujets fondamentaux je voudrais qu'on
éclaircisse ça serait alors qu'on commun
ce seraient des éléments de réflexion
commun et donc à partir de ce moment là
on lancera à la bataille pour les
primaires je ne voudrais pas que la
bataille des personnes domine
complètement la réflexion après chacun
aura ses propositions mais sur le fond
des choses
voyez par exemple la place pour l'islam
modéré
mais qu'est ce que c'est que l'islam
modéré en france et quelle place nous
donnons à l'islam modéré et donc comment
nous faisons en sorte qu' on puisse être
dans la république des combattants
contre l'islamisme intégriste mais en
revanche qu'on soit tolérant sur l'islam
modéré
tout ça ce sont des choses qu'il nous
faut définir tous ensemble et ensuite
dans un an on lancera la primaire
j'espère qu'à ce moment là la primaire
se déroulera à partir de fondement de
penser qu'ils seront structurés bon
avant les primaires il y a les
régionales c'est en décembre 2015
alors est ce que votre a votre avis il
ya beaucoup de régions gagnables par
votre famille politique
quand je dis votre famille politique je
pense à la droite et le centre puisque
apparemment vous allez vous unir c'est
bien cela je crois qu'il ya un bureau
politique un an après ce qu'a dit
monsieur sarkozy ce matin devant les
sénateurs donc devant vous il va
demander à son bureau politique
votre bureau politique composé votre
bureau politique pour ça que je rectifie
mardi de voter sur l'union de la droite
et du centre pour les listes aux
régionales c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
mais nous ne sommes pas encore tout à
fait arrivée au terme de la négociation
en ce qui concerne les têtes de liste
donc parce que il faut aussi y avoir un
accord nous sommes tous sur cette ligne
là la droite et le centre doivent être
unis qu'est ce qui cloche
y a des vous avez des points de friction
je pense que le point de discussion 7
entre les régions qui sont des régions
très favorable et des régions à
certaines donc on ne peut pas par
exemple faire en sorte que lui dit et
les régions certaines
et puis que lui les républicains et les
régions sera la région qui sont mal à
100 de réserve est allé au son il faut
conjuguer le nombre de régions avec la
probabilité de victoire
donc on ne peut pas avoir une majorité
pour les républicains dans les régions
incertaine une majorité pour lui dit
dans les régions certaines donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y à discussion que la
discussion n'est pas achevée à ce votre
choix pour la primaire vous vous le
ferez connaître dans clairement dans un
an je dans un an jour pour jour au mois
de juin j'ai déjà choisi mais je ferai
connaître
bon quand vous avez choisi vous vous
avez déjà choisi votre candidat vous
voulez pas nous le dire mais ce que vous
pouvez peut-être nous dire c'est qu'elle
ligne rouge il faut pas franchir pour
être sûr d'être soutenus par vous ou
est-ce qu'on me plaît c'est la ligne
rouge
moi je pense qu'il faut avoir une grande
conscience des difficultés de la france
donc d'être très ambitieux de jeu de
choisir un projet qui soit un projet
vraiment de rupture et je pense que il
faut avoir une stratégie de
rassemblement et pas une stratégie de
tension est donc à la fois de l'ambition
et du rassemblement c'est je pense sur
ces deux axes là qu'on peut essayer de
bâtir un programme crédible qui devra
être appliquée au moins 50% dans les six
premiers mois l'essentiel doit être fait
dans les six premiers mois
donc préparez auparavant si jeudi alain
juppé je m'exposais un démenti j'allais
dire entre juppé sarkozy mon coeur
balance
et pourquoi vous excluez françois fillon
pardon oui c'est vrai on sait que vous
plaît quand je vous parle de tram-train
fillon alors aujourd'hui donc pour le
moment où je n'ai pas à choisir je suis
pour justement que ledit primaires ne
soit pas anticipé dont je ne vais pas
participer à une anticipation que je ne
souhaite pas encore merci beaucoup
nadège perrine tarneaud arrive
maintenant
donc nicolas sarkozy a rendu visite aux
sénateurs lirez publication mardi en jeu
l'alternance rien n'arrêtera
l'alternance répète l'ancien chef de
l'état tous les élus de son camp sont
d'accord bien sûr mais tous ne
souscrivent pas forcément à son idée
d'une abrogation générale des lois
votées par la gauche sandra cerqueira
c'est bien plus qu'une visite de
courtoisie la cinquième depuis que
nicolas sarkozy a pris la présidence du
parti cajoler les sénateurs les
convaincre du bien fondé de la stratégie
du clivage il souhaiterait une
proposition de loi commune
assemblée/sénat pour abroger toutes les
mesures de françois hollande jugé
néfastes pour les entreprises
et frappé ainsi un grand coup contre le
gouvernement sauf que les sénateurs ne
semble pas très emballé s'opposer oui
mais pas à tout prix au le sénat
toujours a eu l'esprit très indépendant
donc ce n'est pas
un parti faso n'est pas un groupe qui a
le petit doigt sur la couture du
pantalon et qui dit amen à tout ce que
peut demander quelques président de la
république que ce soit ou quel que soit
le parti politique puis il appartient
l'opposition constructive c'est ce que
défend gérard larcher il peut avoir des
échanges vifs avec nicolas sarkozy car
pas question pour lui d'abroger toutes
les lois votées par le gouvernement
socialiste
si jamais la droite gagner la
présidentielle de 2017
chez les républicains du sénat on défend
tout au plus l'idée d'être un
laboratoire pour préparer le programme
de la droite quand on propose une chose
nouvelle par exemple sur le code du
travail par exemple sur la compétitivité
évidemment on est contrainte de
rectifier les dispositions toxiques que
la gauche a voulu voter
le sénat qui est moins dans l'actualité
que l'assemblée nationale - sous la
pression médiatique je pense que il faut
que nous aussi on réfléchisse j'ai lancé
une dizaine de groupes de travail pour
qu'on puisse préparer l'alternance
déjà dans la préparation de l'alternance
l'objectif est bien que le sénat de
droite servent la campagne du futur
candidat républicain comme l'a été le
sénat de gauche pour françois hollande
en 2012 pour la perdre si la droite
revient au pouvoir en 2010 est est-ce
qu'il faut mener cette politique de la
terre brûlée et raser tout ce qui a été
fait pendant le quinquennat de françois
hollande
non évidemment non mais c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut poser le problème il faut
que la loi 10 aux électeurs non mais je
parle pas du tout mais je parle de ce
qui peut être dit ça ce qui est très
important c'est qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire et de dire dans la campagne
électorale ce qu'on veut faire élire
comme on va le faire c'est à dire est ce
qu'on fera un référendum est ce qu'on
fera des zones en moi je pense qu'il
faut faire
l'essentiel des choses dans les six mois
nous devons gouverner donc de dire de
dire clairement dans la campagne qu'est
ce qu'on fait sur les 35 heures est ce
qu'on vient par exemple à 30 leur font
ça fait 15 ans qu'on parle des trains
voilà mais ça fait mais parce que c'est
quand même très important et donc on
décide de le faire et on dit on va le
faire par ordonnance ou vous nous
elysées et on le fait ou vous choisissez
les autres ce ne sera pas fait
mais si vous nous lisez ce sera fait et
voilà comment ce retard qui se dit sur
les 13 14 et 15 ans que l'abandon non
mais attendez
non je vous dis une chose différente je
vous dis que l' ordonnance et sera dans
le débat je vous dis que le projet de
référendum il sera dans le débat c'est à
dire que les mesures que nous voudrons
seront connus et donc moi je souhaite
que nous puissions n'ont pas gagné par
des ambiguïtés
mais nous gagnons part non seulement des
projets mais la manière dont le projet
ne sera fait dans les six mois dans
gagné par des propositions et non pas
gagner en jouant à tout prix comme le
dit pour l'instant nicolas sarkozy sur
des clivages gauche droite
je pense que ce qui compte c'est de
faire un projet mais autant il faut
annoncer le projet il faut aussi annoncé
la gouvernance du projet c'est-à-dire de
dire on se confier aux rats par exemple
du 1er juin au 1er novembre au moins
subtile va falloir de se dire que tout
l'été on transforme la société française
et que ce grand chantier de réforme il
faut le présenter aux français de
manière à ce que on dise finalement on
préfère perdre plutôt que de pas
appliquer notre programme
y'a que moi on a été souvent dans cette
situation maintenant c'est fini
moi je fais partie de ceux qui disent
écoutez il faut qu'on puisse mener notre
programme je préfère qu'on perde si les
français ne veulent pas qu'on réforme la
france
ils choisiront les autres mais s'ils
veulent qu'on réforme la france ont
l'art et fermera mener votre programme
ça veut dire quand même détricoter
certaines réformes qui sont des
marqueurs du quinquennat de françois
hollande on se voit ailleurs l'objectif
mariage pour tous à la réforme du
collège ou encore à la réforme
territoriale qui a été très combattu ici
au sénat l'objectif c'est pas tout à
fait ça l'objectif c'est quand même
l'emploi à revenir par exemple si aucun
de ces trois textes on pourra revenir
sur un certain nombre de textes
je pense qu'il faut tout arrêter la
sphère du mariage pour tous je pense que
les droits des accusés à écrire on a dû
comme comme ça a été dit par voie ce
soit un havre âge le mot no non non non
on peut on peut on peut redéfinir les
choses n'est donc on a décidé de
travailler sur ma job engagé le travail
sur ce sujet donc il ya un certain
nombre d'orientations qui sont pris je
pense que nous avons des textes que sur
les que les socialistes ont fait voter
qui ne sont pas forcément des problèmes
pour nous je pense à la loi sur les
renseignements dont nous avons là vous
l'a prouvé aujourd'hui sur mixte
paritaire ce matin qui fait qu'on a
trouvé un texte commun d'ailleurs a par
ailleurs su sénat un peu des celtics un
peu
des scellements français la loi
programme a mobilisé territoriale la
france tient au coeur des sénateurs ici
par exemple redécoupage des régions
nicolas sarkozy lui l'a dit qu'il
fallait revenir en arrière est ce que
vous êtes d'accord est ce que ce sera
possible
saint jean du j'en suis pas sûr et donc
il faudra voir un peu ce que vont donner
ces nouvelles grandes régions est ce que
ces grandes régions vont s'imposer ou
est-ce qu'elles vont être quelque chose
qui finalement apparaîtra comme très
artificielle n'existeront kpn tendance à
nous nous verrons un peu mais
suffisamment pour voir si elles ont
trouvé leur place en tout cas auprès des
territoires moi je pense que ce sera
difficile de revenir sur sept ce type
d'élection donc globalement sur
l'ensemble de la réforme territoriale ce
qu'on a l'impression quand même on a le
sentiment que les élus territoriaux sont
un peu exaspéré par tous ces changements
de pied je crois il ya deux voies si
vous voulez y avait celle que nicolas
sarkozy avait dit ce rapprochement
département-région seuil est l'hôte voix
c'était des grandes régions et des
départements
donc moi je serai est ce que ce
intéressés par cette logique là mais à
ce moment là il faut renforcer le
département ce qu'on n'a pas trouvé
intelligent de la part du gouvernement
s'était dit vouloir des grandes régions
et de supprimer le département
moi je crois qu'il faut renforcer le
département quitte à l'agrandir je crois
qu'il y a des départements qui devraient
par exemple rassemblé 2,2 et pardon je
crois que la charente et la charente
maritime pourrait faire un département
peut-être que la vienne et deux sèvres
pour faire un département dans une
grande région aquitaine ont pu avoir
donc il ya des projets de réforme ça je
pense qu'il faudra en discuter que le
ccnr devra discuter mais le c est
justement le rôle du sénat effectivement
d'être le laboratoire de l'alternance
c'est le monde et me dise est de
préparer et atteindre de préparer la
table mais non pas en étant aux ordres
d'un parti mais de regarder les
problèmes de la société ou d'un autre et
où d'un homme mais de regarder les
problèmes société française et apporter
des solutions
je pense que sur le territoire nous
avons à observer ce qui va se passer et
à tirer est les leçons de l'expérience
de tous les élus que nous représentons
et donc le sénat ne doit pas partir
qu'est-ce que je dois cassé dans ce
qu'ont fait les autres mais ce qu'est ce
que je dois apporter comme réponse aux
problèmes des français
donc on ne part pas de l'opposition si
l'opposition a fait des choses nouvelles
on les changera mais c'est pas par
rapport à l'opposition c'est par rapport
aux problèmes des français
et s'il faut résoudre les problèmes des
français aujourd'hui il faut qu'il faut
gagner en efficacité et en budget je ne
veux pas revenir
forcément à la loi sarkozy si la loi
sarkozy est la bonne réponse viendra
mais s'il y a par exemple des grandes
régions qui s'affirme et à ce moment là
la création de grands départements est
d'arriver à l'idée de michel debré
d'avoir 60 départements
peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui ce
qui serait une voix meilleur je partirai
du problème des français et pas de la
stratégie droite gauche donc être
constructif on va parler un peu de vous
maintenant jean pierre raffarin puisque
un documentaire a été réalisé sur vous
par cyril viguier il sera diffusé la
semaine prochaine sur france 3 je vous
propose de regarder un extrait c'est
christophe barbier le directeur la
rédaction de l'express qui parle de vous
il parle notamment de votre avenir
possible
on les écoute comment être indispensable
au prochain pouvoir la droite gagne en
2017 supposons et un président est-ce
qu'il a besoin de rafah
enfin n'est pas président du sénat
raffarin c'est un bon la vieille pour
une grand gros département il va pas
revenir présentent pas tous chantent pas
besoin rafa c'est un ancien prémices
mais il y en a beaucoup
pas besoin à raffarin c'est la chine
j'ai présidé ce comité francine et
j'allais en chine et raffarin d y aller
la semaine suivant et je lis dans les
journaux qu'il va sans doute renoncer à
son voyage à cause de la grippe alors je
m'appelle au téléphone il ne fait pas ça
il faut pas reculer devant des frappes
un peu plat des deux cas sans votre
visite et y ait des allures c'est la
realpolitik d'avenir dans les années
2010 et 2022 ce sera quoi l'actualité
des révoltes en chine la pollution en
chine
la guerre des monnaies l'homme politique
qui n'aura pas un bon contact avec la
chine eh bien il part avec une jambe en
moins
venir avec raffarin quand je rencontre
le président chinois nommé raffarin au
quai d'orsay c'est déjà avoir une grande
porte d'entrée en chine
le job
de votre rêve enfin le globe qui vous
ferait rêver écoutez leurs séjours
affaires étrangères avec la politique je
ne suis plus l'étape des rêves est donc
enfin quand même les ambitions des
ambitions peut-être oui mais en tout cas
c'est une responsabilité passionnante
forte mais ça ne peut se faire que en
grande proximité avec un président de la
république
ce sont des sujets qui se partagent la
politique étrangère de la france c'est
quelque chose qu'on apprend on fait il
faut il faut avoir pour le président un
respect une proximité et donc tout ça on
en reparlera le moment venu mais c'est
une mission qu'on accomplit pas seul
on accomplit avec un président puisqu'il
faut que votre candidat passe le cap des
primaires on a confié nous verrons tout
ça c'est bien c'est bien trop loin et
soit élu derrière mais vous savez très
franchement je suis très heureux
aujourd'hui dans l'action politique
parce que je suis passionné par la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat est au fond je n'aspire à rien
d'autre je veux dans mon département des
projets on va inaugurer un centaure parc
dans la vienne dans quelques jours le 10
juillet mille emplois directs et
indirects
ça c'est vraiment du bonheur j'ai un
autre grand projet avec joël robuchon
qui dans mon propre département
j'ai beaucoup de choses sinon que la
chine d'un côté le terrain de l'autre au
fond je suis rien pas d'usure 2010 n
2010 est non ça ne fait pas partie d'une
échéance là dedans a semblé l'iris du
liège je travaille sur des projets qui
vont se dérouler dans mon département du
10 juillet prochain que le centaure par
cas là des projets vont 2022 2025
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui me
hante je suis un homme politique apaisée
ce qui me permet de parler avec
gentillesse ou avec sévérité vis-à-vis
des autres vous n'avez jamais la
tentation finalement de jeter l'épongé
après matignon c'est éprouvant quand
même d'être premier ministre après les
deux échecs aussi ici à la présidence du
sénat ait jamais eue d'usure 2 tentation
de bon
pour moi le combat c'est la dignité de
la politique si vous avez le sentiment
qu'à un moment vous avez quelque chose à
apporter mois les batailles au sénat
j'ai pas vécu ça comme comme d'aimables
moi je pensais que pour le sénat il
fallait faire un certain nombre de
choses j'ai voulu les proposer on les
prend on les prend pas et puis je suis
allé à terre étrangère et puis je
travaille que le président actuel je ne
sais pas je ne fais pas de tout cela les
enjeux de ma vie je suis quelqu'un qui a
une réflexion personnelle qui est qu'il
ya une religion qui sait ce que c'est
qu'un peu le spirituel
donc je mesure aussi ce qu'est la limite
d'un certain nombre de choses donc je
suis pas complètement ligoté par une
ambition et c'est ce qui m'a toujours
éloigner de la tentation et c'est vrai
si sedan il est aujourd'hui c'est que
oui ça peut ça me donne une sorte de
désintéressement que vous alarmer d'être
libre je faisais le éloigné de
l'ambition que c'est cette idée que
l'ambition dé vos retours et détruit à
la terre de vous tous pas bêtement
truite de temps la dame être stupéfié
par le spectacle autour de huy nga
maintenance mais je sais les
républicains mais rien n'est meilleur
aussi le savez moi j'ai connu plusieurs
présidents de la république de pau de
près je connais jusqu'à il se trouve que
mitterrand était picto-charentais que
mon père avait eu avec lui dans le
gouvernement demande et france dont je
les ai connus
j'ai évidemment nicolas sarkozy et
jacques chirac
je vois que pour arriver à cette
ambition là il ya des conséquences
terribles
je pense que les très grands arrivent à
maîtriser un peu les choses mais c'est
quand même extrêmement difficiles et
quand vous voyez un peu
dans leur vie personnelle est là c'est
qu'il a laissé des traces est assez
forte donc il ya quelque chose de
destructeur dans cette ambition dans
cette élection qui la plus difficile au
monde alors il ya une expression qu'on
connaissait jean pierre raffarin c'est
mieux vous perdre une élection que
perdre son âme
vous en avez utilisé une autre au cours
de cette émission vieux mieux vaut
perdre une élection si ça n'est pas pour
réformer la france
ça c'est le message pour tous les
candidats à la primaire a je pense
qu'aujourd'hui lit où nous en sommes
nous ne pouvons plus jouer l'ambiguïté
vaut mieux perdre que de l'impuissance
je pense que c'est ça la clé de l'avenir
aujourd'hui si on est dans la situation
d'extrême gravité dans laquelle nous ça
si on en a conscience
il faut proposer des solutions et dire
aux français les solutions qu'on propose
et c'est les français qui choisiront
c'est à eux de choisir
ils sont assez quand je fais confiance à
leur jugement moi je fais confiance aux
équipes j'ai pas peur de l'élection
j'entends des gens qu'il y a il faudrait
pas pouvoir faire deux mandats de suite
parce que s'il était réélu il vraiment
non sire il faut faire confiance aux
français
les français ont le bon sens pour
choisir mais pour cela nous on doit pas
jouer l'ambiguïté et si on joue
l'ambiguïté on débouchera sur
l'impuissance et c'est contraire à ce
qu'il faut pour la france
merci jean pierre raffarin merci perrine
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi la
semaine prochaine notre invité sera
françois bayrou a très vite